you saw we made some very good progress
we'll come back tonight I believe at
that time we'll have the votes to finish
this once and for all it just reminds me
of what my father always told me it's
not how you start it's how you finish
and now we have to finish for the
American public because it took this
long now we learned how to govern
so now we'll be able to get the job
positive spin on things the dam could
finally be breaking in the battle for
the gavel as we're calling it Kevin
McCarthy inching a little closer than
ever to capturing house speaker but he's
still coming up a little short McCarthy
was able to flip 15 out of the 21
Republican holdouts but it wasn't enough
he needs a few more votes to save yours
truly from the embarrassment of calling
Kevin speaker for the last few months
but right now the Republicans are taking
a timeout until 10 to gorge on pizza and
figure out a plan McCarthy has
reportedly been cutting deals and
offering concessions to win over the
never Kevin's yet he apparently still
has some work to do
several believe that one earns the
position of speaker by raising enormous
sums of money and there is no doubt that
the individual that was nominated by Mr
Garcia is the LeBron James of special
interest fundraising in this town there
is nobody better but I would suggest
that there are qualifications for
speaker that are far more important
there are attributes that are far more
important
meanwhile the liberal media has been
having a field day gobbling up every
little morsel of Republican infighting
and of course using it all to paint the
Republicans is racist
Republicans love to talk about black
people in two specific ways
the first way is to boost the identity
politics while patting themselves on the
back the second thing Republicans tend
to do is to play the match game matching
impressive black Democratic candidates
with black conservatives sort of a
they've got one so we've got one Gambit
some of these individuals were people
who were really only elected based on a
litmus test to stop the tide of
diversity in the country the Browning of
America the fears that surround that
it's terrifying
so Kevin McCarthy said that this is
making the Republican conference
stronger do you think it is
[Laughter]
actually I I do think it is and you know
I've thought about this for a couple of
days and what has happened is for the
last 40 years the position of speaker
has become more and more powerful and
now what's happened is you've got these
these outliers if you can call them that
um who are saying no we want certain
things and what we want is we want a
commitment from McCarthy that there
won't be any more trillion dollar
funding bills uh instead we'll have a
separate appropriation bills and that's
a good thing for the American people and
they're saying that you know we've got a
commitment now to get a a bill to the
floor to vote on term limits that's a
good thing for the American people
um a legislation now as a result of
their demands on McCarthy allows more
people everybody to put amendments on a
bill that wasn't allowed before so you
have to I kind of kind of did a
turnaround myself and I said you know
what these guys they stood strong the
men and the women whoever doesn't matter
but this is democracy in action this is
them saying we're not going to get this
after you're the speaker these are
important things and they held out and
Leadership had no choice but to work
with them and I think that Congress is
going to be better off in the long run
oh okay so you have changed your mind a
little bit that is an about face like
I've never seen
it out so what I said yesterday Greg was
I don't want to see the sausage being
made and I wished it had been done
earlier and why'd you go to Vienna not
for the food for the sausages Greg I
know you've been
pouring over this country ah you know
that this is probably well first of all
joy joy uh what's your name Reed saying
that about you know uh uh we've got one
so they've got they've got to get one
how race isn't that kind of like behind
the whole diversity equity and inclusion
agenda is about building up a diversity
and so she's now criticizing the
Republicans for putting forth a black
candidate and then you have Mara gay is
that her name right she's talking about
the Browning of America remember she
thought that 300 and what 340 million
dollars would give a million dollars to
every American you might want to stay
out of this but this is I've never found
anything so it's so amusing and as
tedious as the first time I met you
I agree I agree with the judge I think
that conflict keeps you on your toes
right the reason why the five is so
successful is because we we didn't have
a bunch of agreeable voices we actually
have dissenting voices and we'll have
one voice from one side that kind of you
know pulls everybody out so you're not
always in unison it's Unison so you
don't end up like a Mindless smelly
robot you know like on Morning Joe or
the or the view uh we create this kind
of tension and tension builds education
it makes people smarter you admit when
you're right you admit when you're wrong
but here's my problem okay and this is
going to sound like I'm whining because
I am whining why are you doing this
McCarthy on a Friday night at 10 pm I
have a show if this is preempted by you
McCarthy I'm becoming an anti-mccartheid
I never Kevin I'll be a never a cabin
I'm gonna also I'm gonna go on a
commenting strike I'm not gonna comment
at all and for as long as this goes
around so why don't you just wait until
Monday people have been dying for you to
go in a commentary
Kevin finally did it any uh your sense
of the timing of this thing do you think
as people suggest at 10 o'clock might be
it it could be we're hearing a couple of
members who were absent today will be
there tonight and they will vote in the
Pro McCarthy Camp
um he still is not across the finish
line so we'll just have to tune in
sorry Greg I think it's going to happen
tonight around 11 o'clock just on a
Friday night but I I do something about
the last week I mean since voting
started on Tuesday and it was clear from
the beginning and actually going into
the vote before way ahead of time months
ahead of time that this was he was not
going to have the boats right away uh
these 20 Republicans have been falsely
accused of having no specific list of
concessions that they wanted no specific
agenda that they wanted that it was all
just personal they didn't like Kevin
McCarthy and that's why they're holding
up the vote clearly that's not true chip
Roy has been negotiating this behind the
scenes they have a whole list of things
they're able to get which includes
putting more of the power in the
Committees rather than the speaker's
office you know if you're going to fund
a new government program you have to get
rid of a government program and Byron
Donald said that last week you said it
again today and he actually switched his
vote today which is progress
um and you know when it comes to the
rules committee which is what the
conservatives have been elected to do
chip Roy insisted that they have enough
people on that committee to stop bills
that are bad from even coming up on the
floor for a vote so I think what's
happened over the course of four days
four days is not a long time has been
great for the country to see I wish that
not just the election for speaker were
televised like it was but every single
vote that they take on the floor that
includes funding things with taxpayer
money that the American people would see
that I know for two years they've taken
a break because of proxy voting and
Nancy Pelosi hasn't required that people
show up for work we have had this kind
of debate in a very long time since but
foreign to most people but I think it's
a good thing and I think that these
conservatives who got these concessions
especially after all the pressure this
week should be applauded
let's turn it over to the Democrat here
I'm an American yeah who happens to be
you are a Democrat allegedly Harold we
still haven't seen your birth
certificate
so I think what do you think about
what's going on here so I I think that
we didn't have to go through all of this
to get what the judge and I think what
Katie's articulated really well
um it's true in the last two years
because the covet we weren't able to see
these things but when I was in Congress
C-SPAN aired all of this stuff they
aired every vote even aired the after uh
hour things that happened in the
Congress meaning you could go down and
occupy an hour of time and talk about
whatever you want to talk about two
what's Curious to me is they're in the
majority now so why do you they're
fighting themselves and this fight was
amongst the Republicans between the
Republicans to figure out can we hold
ourselves accountable to be accountable
to the people which is a curious thing
to me
um one would think for the last 25 years
when you consider only two or three
budgets have been done on time
it's not because Democrats were the
problem or Republicans were the problem
they all were the problem so if they
want and I applaud them for this if they
want to ensure that amendments come back
into the process and they're voting on
the floor I think that is the right
thing to do we didn't have to do this to
do that if they want to ensure that we
don't pass Omnibus bills anymore the
only reason you pass those big bills at
the end of the year is because they
didn't do their job during the course of
the year so just do your job to put the
country through this is an amazing thing
now I'm interested in seeing the rules
package when it does get finally drawn
up how many people are going to be on
the rules committee who actually know
what the rules committee does or are
they just there to say we have this one
thing that we're concerned about and
we're going to make sure every that this
is all that we do the congress not only
funds the government the Congress has to
pontificate and have Vision about what's
going forward I didn't hear any of that
from these guys today but look I want
them to get seated I want them sworn in
um my party lost if McCarthy is the
person they want I know in person I
think he's a nice guy I hope he's able
to manage this this group but I got to
tell you after negotiating a lot of that
power from the speaker's job itself it
is a constitutional officer I do hope
that some of those who are so uh just
agitated with with Kevin understand that
this is the speaker's role and it's not
just going to be here for two years this
is a constitutional officer second in
line to be president of the United
States so hooray let's get it over with
let's get it done and let's get let's
get to work for the American people okay
and we'll have live coverage do you
think the Americans are watching do they
really are they really like broken up
over this nobody's dying nobody's being
attacked this is what politicians do
they political National Security yeah
they just waste our time I thought you
were going on a commentary strike hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else